hey what's up we're gonna play some
poker today for Bobby the snake leave
whatever this is whatever this is it's
not gonna work
the godfather al Madrigal al you've been
full of [ __ ] since I met you
the angry Buddha Eddie Pepitone now I'll
switch the mama bear Jay Larson fell
shuffle all day and me hon Robert if you
say I look like [ __ ] Opie Cunningham
with cancer am I gonna have a problem
with it can we do a thing when we
introduce ourselves
I'll start I'm Bobbie Lee Hom the
Sidewinder yeah and I'm not a
professional poker player I played a
couple of times and I'm really just
happy to be here from San Diego but you
should say well you're far away go ahead
part of the boys club of america hey i'm
bill burr I'm from Albuquerque New
Mexico and I never played cards growing
up it was like an old lady thing so I
don't play golf or poker go ahead out
I really don't play poker either or golf
you do all these things all these things
I have a lot of anxiety whenever I'm not
working so and like bill says I can't be
alone with my own thoughts
I'm the bitter Buddha and I play cards I
went through a bit of a gambling
addiction used to take money from my
mother's purse to play with the kids in
the neighborhood in Staten Island and
then I got caught taking the money and
then I said [ __ ] it I'm not gonna play
again that's true how old were you I was
about 30 31 look I want to tell the kids
of America about the middle-aged people
of America if you're middle-aged America
that you could take money from your
mother's purse at any age she'll still
love you
she'll still love you what is she gonna
do
we gamble growing up as kids that's what
we did remember the BC scandal and like
nine just see the name and where you're
from it looks play that's what a man you
say you're naming the thing and then
we'll just go play better like it's a
story that's true kind of story things
people expands people do different
things some people get on stage and get
naked some tell stories this is what
we're gonna do small blind big blind see
what he just did yeah so let's do it
yeah
[Applause]
people think Hold'em is the truest form
of Poker it seems like a cool game to be
to be good at what is this they give you
two cards you put some money in the pot
there's a river you take a look at these
first two cards see what you got and you
bet appropriately
who are you I don't play poker at all I
used to watch the thing on ESPN why do
you keep asking me questions about poker
[Music]
[ __ ] degenerate that's the only time
you use that word when you put a
prestige gambler get your small up and
your big o one and two please oh nice
yeah but that could be a block I could
be bluffing yeah would be leading us
down that bad to do it a poker table
whoa it's the human mister me two bucks
if you wanted well there's nothing on
the table how do I know what's going on
also you have what's in your hand
dissipate yeah so there has to be at all
you guys are in trouble there's two
dollars all right now we'll burn I'll do
the flop two eight nine because everyone
had to throw it come on Jay what the I'm
not controlling this and who's it to
it's to you me yep all right I'll throw
in five five bones I have a question
what's that thing where you have the
same color in the symbol but all that's
flush yes yeah five a kind shoe don't
listen to sting shape of my heart on the
way over here he breaks down all the
suits
wait so he bet a five you're a amana
urine yeah I'm gonna uh I don't like the
looks of this I'm gonna say I'm gonna
stop
like it what do I say yeah I'm out my
fault I'm up I'm falling - I'm up
are you ready [ __ ]
I should have [ __ ] stayed tend to me
mm-hmm it's me you know and what do we
get one more this is though this is the
the river now you can bet on that I get
that right you can bet whatever you want
again those are ten I know I'm gonna
raise you two more tens exciting now you
have to put in one more 10 more you
could raise all right how come you guys
wear sunglasses I mean I'm not a high
name like this was like you supposed to
do that if you'd pass a lot with what
you don't have you done so now it's you
guys are both in so let's show what do
you got I got it straight if you don't
feel emotion oh [ __ ] six seven eight
nine ten yeah I have a pair of nines he
doesn't know I know I know he doesn't
know I play to win every hand and we're
gonna be able to benefit for Eddie
Pepitone attempt it is not textbook
poker at all I mean this is really as
bad as you can play it's a little
upsetting basically I got stuck teaching
four guys how to play poker
I'm one of the best kind of pro
corporate players because I don't know
what the [ __ ] I'm doing
you would think playing with people who
don't know how to play poker do you have
the advantage but you don't the people
that have the advantage of the people
who don't know how to play cuz they're
gonna sit then you're like are they
bluffing are they not and you can't tell
if they're bluffing or not because they
just don't even know what the [ __ ]
they're doing this thing yeah why
wouldn't I be in and it's like splash in
the pot they try to play mind games with
me because it's the white thing it's
fine I'm stronger than that I'm strong
for when you look at like the
professional poker players you see the
toll it takes on them their dress like
you know in Goodfellas like you know
with what's-her-face is like everything
was like thrown together a bunch of
cheap you know patent leather that's all
of that [ __ ] but then they'll just have
some crazy watch and you be like okay
they want big money that week I want to
play as much as possible if that means
holding on to horrible cards and seeing
as many cards as a boss
I'd like to go home and just be with my
dogs
I always want to cut out and trust you
all right so what do you do with the
cigar ash in here put it in here
everybody to everybody you gently roll
it off and then it should look like the
the back end of the Batmobile so your
small blind one bills big blind too in
so you all need to have one in no matter
what burr needs to in no matter what I
don't get bad just keeps it going and it
makes sure that like now he's guaranteed
he's in fur to see the fly no matter
what because he's already bought it I'm
out that's horrible terrible it's not
easy I know what does any wanna do you
play the Vic whatever this is whatever
this is it's not gonna work
look at this the guy just learned today
and he already gets it yeah if he's got
[ __ ] in his hands places there's no way
if it came around him again he's just
saving like a dollar or two right he
just saved two bucks yeah but hey it's
gonna be two bucks more than now he's
gonna go asia's or cheap
I wasn't oh I say you're bad drivers and
you should have stayed in you don't care
about being a bad driver do you I mean
that people say that I'm loving this
sideways sit with the leg crossed and
I'm still intimidated like he's got
something what it's like playing with
cake I'm in so it's to you now you
decide if you would like all right and
are them putting you to okay Brno here I
mean you know I'm playing I'm playing
cuz it said no I mean if he wants to win
a row so throw in bill did you burn one
here and then you late the next three
here
what do you mean burn when they put it
down face down we don't see it's just
called the burn card you burn before the
flop why is the burn I don't know why
the burn so just throw three over yeah
just [ __ ] up that Bluff us all right
you guys watch the show long-lost family
where does that all it's on TLC it's a
great show
I'm not on it but it Wow I don't promote
my own [ __ ] that would be great if you
did
yeah have you guys seen Harold and Kumar
long-lost family can finish yeah all
right it's like when a a woman or a man
gives her kid up for adoption but they
reunite like 30 or 40 years reality but
the reality show now my check it out
though every [ __ ] time it's a cry
fest more like not my house Kevin I cry
J yeah yeah he did that he using a
Korean dude yeah he met his his mom she
was a hooker
Oh was she I'm asking there was no
question mark on the end of that was it
you know what Billy B yeah yeah I'm a
mom I check I call River J comes out as
well I'm done so it's to you four
thousand four fifteen he bet ten on
opening so you know he's he that
carrying this Boy Wonder these were
those are a ten so you know that what
are you he met 15 teen yeah that says
something when you throw those down so
he can also go to your cabin fire else
class on a fog up if you throw those
down I don't here's ten here fifteen and
I raise you fifteen-year-old I can raise
again right sure and I raise you thirty
okay
thirty and I raise you forty no you're
not gonna be in the game feed me the
last ten now I want to see you dead 40
years 40 good to see you burn all right
are you raising the dead take that [ __ ]
out anybody do it more no you don't my
father will wire me money if I need all
right all right there we go let's go
this way
burn and then one iron and then goin yep
[Music]
and what Eddie deserves the money just
at 20 bucks 20 and I'll raise you 20
he's got an ace in his hand he have to
be good and 1/8 I hope not
what do you wanna do here if you look if
you get yourself knocked out this early
you gotta stand in the corner like a
Blair Witch
for the rest of the [ __ ] game just
land which I like it remember that
sounds [ __ ] horror movie made a ton
of money
I loved it oh yeah yeah who's showing
first oh do I show now unless you want
to raise Emma bet him I don't know what
you have any money left
I got that I got that and then 9 what's
your what's that what is your it's your
best five cards Oh tea split the parts
oh that's [ __ ] that's [ __ ] we're
saying you have to have a winner
Eddie don't cry man you're saying you're
gonna cry [ __ ] no I'm a game plan
it's called gut instinct primal
instinctual need to dominate
I can't believe as many people fold so
we're really as they do I maybe not be
I'm not a good poker player but when
you're playing with people make sure
they're idiots
they're gazelle I'm the lion and I'll
[ __ ] eat all of it even the dick I'll
get the pick-6 strip clubs it true me
yeah
I'm rarely gonna walk away with any
money it's a lot of bravado like oh you
know we're having fun but they're not
and and I enjoy that this is when you
know somebody's not a serious gambler
this one you don't see
they come back with this mama Celeste
for [ __ ] I hate me see those dudes
getting the massages at the table very
serious what on the poker been there for
hours
thanks for the Costco pizza your first
try ever at home if you came up with
this you be like that wasn't bad yeah it
wasn't bad
Oh whoever made this hey nice nice try
great attempt all the friendly chatter
stops and the sunglasses go on Howard
[ __ ] oh yeah Chi doesn't count
everyone first five cards it's a real
question why the [ __ ] doesn't he just
put two in cuz he's gonna do it anyway
because it's called the small and the
big if it gets to him and he doesn't
want to play the hand he can but he
doesn't know what his cards are right
now he doesn't know what his court
basketball game like why do they have to
do a tip it's just the way it go would
he bail out before even having his cards
no one's gonna bail out right that
should be your [ __ ] you're gonna get
your cards now but you have to be in for
two you need one me let me a confused
kid you meet one more guy in this
players devil dude get my poor heart
again I don't know this isn't even real
cheese is coming out of my mouth umm you
put he puts two people he's I know but
I'm just saying if he put till I put two
everyone puts two then he doesn't have
to put another one in this is good one
extra thing that he has to do he's
literally arguing for me yeah but I
finally watch my point your point do it
do it do it I don't putting it I haven't
seen my cards I don't need to oh we are
smoosh I [ __ ] up I [ __ ] up JJ I
[ __ ] oh hey I motion up we just ignore
him i second why do we have to use cards
why are they cards here's a special out
you can do what he wants
the billboards all over town it was
racist stuff is the matter I'm gonna
build is window I pass I'm done
no you're not though wait for the flop
could you already pay some bucket dolla
do oh you keep on MADtv your minute ha
ha ha [ __ ] hanging for a round I'll
go back all right let's do it
burn one and then flip three burn one
and then do a lot of Spades a lot of
Spades a lot of straights
so it goes to burr and then the you know
then it goes around mm-hmm dad Jack
hello he was so polite are you gonna
break through he the plane ease of the
procedure the crew what are you doing
what a [ __ ] so now Madrigal if you
want in I'll be always in Boerne one
looking that oh six is on the board
he's got a good hand now yeah beautiful
you're gonna pull just gonna hand it
over to me bird takes it let's see what
it would have been look you would have
got a [ __ ] flush Alberta beat you
Oh in your trip sixes but he would have
the flush I had a flush
yeah I know but you have yeah she had a
seven foot okay so you did at the club
so you were the one verse five Susan two
sevens huh you did it but I'm saying if
the Turner yeah flush you know what
gradually I mean the river all right
sorry dealing with the happy guy over
here yeah Wade from Ohio there's this
small and big blind thanks for [ __ ] your
God hello Bobby you know buddy I'll show
this ya a picture yeah okay you might
not mean not gonna get old
Allah Pepitone and burnt then back to
you it's smaller don't do it Bobby I'm
in bold
al come in Al's in Burr don't
you're not folded okay alright let's do
a flop
nice I'm guessing cuz nobody went whoo
you guys done that's your call it's your
bet or you can check Leah's gone
he's [ __ ] done you know he's gonna
play this all I have he's doing it you
know really doing the math unlike what
the percentages are who could have a
king or a pair up and keep it up stop
stop no more Asian Shh the pro I'm not
Rain Man no I can't rock out and I've
had conversations you're clearly so no
more i jugs my small dick liquor store
you touch you buy no bras oh I know you
just sit down play yeah
all right so let's go everyone's in
everyone's accounted for the river no
you get your flop then the turn is we
just like ties together the flop to the
last card of the river I'll check I'll
check I'll check - great there you go
what card is this Bobby the fifth one
the river I got real fours that was
stupid I should yeah of course you
shouldn't see you out of ace high yes
ace high [ __ ] though yeah so what do you
have what oh yeah
[Applause]
Wow isn't it fun when you find out all
that way you can't do I know there's
some a tremendous amount of [ __ ] in
this game I have a lot of thoughts that
thoughts about a lot of things I may not
reveal all those things right now
because it could get me in trouble
because I'm a hostile I don't really
like Eddie Pepitone and I can't figure
out why my strategy is to bluff I'm like
yeah come on you gonna play or you gonna
sit there like an idiot
but underneath I'm like please when is
the shoot over I'm a little drunk off
the Scotch can I say this yeah because I
was in an improv troupe called mixed
nuts and you t'see for a while let's
watch the over talk go ahead okay that
was called interracial and you guys were
crazy our nemesis with scrambled eggs
they were incredible scrambled eggs
no EG z o scrambled eggs like they were
in the womb and Oh somebody tried to
abort us but they didn't miles and it's
you've seen them 14 now who knows what's
gonna come out of our mouths you've seen
them and what's worse improv McHenry's
up or acapella groups 12 improv group
names house lease is something we can't
do okay no I put one down what happen
one yeah and then flop first birth yes
Jesus guys does anybody here in an
acapella group I'm out so it's the Eddie
how about Jenn tend to you huh I'd be
[ __ ] looked me yeah you did you say
[ __ ] but he better so he bet first
nobody just took a peek good Starbucks
no it's 10 it's 10 bucks
well it's only 12 I [ __ ] raise you to
raise it to who little [ __ ] pasty legs
like me don't do it Bobby don't do
uh-huh
put it in my pocket just two bucks to
you how does this sunglasses more
transparent I think they're insect and I
raised 10 go yeah he just raised 10 to
YouTube this is a real ego game this is
magical
this is how he does right here first of
all you have like the mature you wait
you know what
you are a good poker player Billy Billy
Billy goes through all the all right
check bars check deterrence don't see
anybody else picking up the vibe that
Bobby Lee just wants to get the [ __ ] out
of here
yes yes Bobby has a good Bobby goes
through a lot with everything I'm not
buying that
oh the mortgage all right so mandrels to
you [ __ ] check to you Bobby do you want
to try and just say all right let's show
more yet by the pot was that twenty or
thirty thirty-two ul how about Bobby
take it thank you thank you play you
little hit Rick but you won't show here
hand all right
small blind will be 5 then 10 and then
you know you guys pay for your porn do
you watch it for free [ __ ] car you
know I my favorite about these three
chips are oh yes you dumb [ __ ] you're
not even looking at you because it takes
too long if you want it in its tenth
then too Bobby
you'd have to do five what you have to
do five years and then now is a chance
to raise gotcha perfect
all right nice remember she says out out
you win no it's me and you again
this time it's gonna badly for you you
guys are like Walter Matthau and Jack
Lemmon without a help no is it weird to
watch porn that's like older men but
kind of sadly younger girls I mean I
think that's a little creepy but that's
it's out there for a reason I guess
right older men and why is that your
thing asking for a friend
I mean him no I think he's just
inserting himself into the equation who
would I be in that so after a while if
he sees two young people going at it
he just gets like you know like sad
about all the time that's gone by but if
he season all the guy
a younger chick he still is hope ya
think you're they a that's it yeah but
mine is like I I motion for this whole
thing to be dismissed
hey maybe I'm gonna be your attorney for
ya no no I just all day and I just feel
guilty watching it I don't really forget
off to it I just it's interesting to me
that's all you just put it on the big
screen in your house like honey put on
the old people [ __ ] your girlfriend
is extremely attract thank you and she
knows about you going to old Jay and all
this they go together
no like I have my iPad and I'll do this
that's like the debts like the poor
man's robot you know they have like for
me yeah you know to me it's like you
can't afford it's like when someone
can't afford a Bentley they buy a 300
yeah he can't afford one of theirs at
for 10 grand you can buy a [ __ ] robot
that you can bang are you serious now in
the New York Post no it's gotta be
eighty five hundred dollars you can get
a real doll but doesn't move around
there's no [ __ ] thing we'll do your
dish afterwards do don't laugh at all
your stories you know [ __ ] it whatever
you want but get your robot grab you
couldn't a robot hurt you it cares
someone a malfunctioning movie what you
just pour water on it if it gets out of
line
I'm out I'm out guys I'm not even in its
down oh [ __ ] Eddie can bet and then you
turn about how much other robots what
are they going Angie they're ten grand I
was in the [ __ ] paper it set the
price New York Times ten grand you go
buy it
I'm gonna scan that [ __ ] thing and
I'm gonna send it to you do you think
you could buy on it could you anybody
help me buy one of those [ __ ] things
and still have like a decent
relationship with you with you no no I
don't think because you start taking a
robot on trips you start taking the
robot on for what it trades like that
this I'm honey I'm going to skip it's
just a day trip a day trip is okay you
keep going all high with the robot but
you can't happen
let me York
the worst player at the table Bobby Lee
well you know people thought I was
counting cards I was counting Jay
Larson's chins underneath his neck that
counted 14 if Jay Larson was not at this
game it would be a disaster it really
would I think if you're a poker fan and
you were watching this you like Jesus
Christ that you Andy now it's not that
confusing Eddie Pepitone didn't really
not a smoke a cigar was all like look
like a joke cigar like someone lit it
and already exploded in his mouth how
many times I tell him yeah now you do
this we use like now what do I do Jay I
don't have any leakage this this stool
is dry I'm almost out of liquor I'm
going big on this one all right so how
much 10 bucks to you and can I raise it
you can raise it sure okay so 10 to me
and I'll raise it 20 [ __ ] you Eddie
Pepitone I'm just plain you already in
for your small right yes I can't afford
this can I check you have to put another
10 in about five a five a five it was
five ten I'm stop can I check P raise 20
so you have to a 20 if you go 20 I have
to promise Allison I don't my glasses on
that's right it took my line what is it
20 right now I think we should play
talking this run in those pockets go
[Music]
[ __ ] good man you pair it up it goes -
ow ow I like your hat extra extra read
all the powder ah that's great Japanese
it you should be like one newspaper boy
for like today Alicia she's not wearing
makeup anymore nobody cares I love it
that was like a big move we live in a
police state one terrorist attack
fascism is coming and also Alicia Keys
does it women
you know about a Python yes alligator
down in Gainesville Eddie Eddie Eddie
now burn he's going go now hum I love
the accent came over here like some bad
Mexican accent alright just one okay
that's the [ __ ] three I was waiting
for first guy nothing burns got nothing
extra extra read all about it both
finally gets his three in the flop one
which is up 10 and then another 10 so
it's 20 you go to the cash he's got a
pair of fours before well you know what
I have he said he's got a pair you
didn't know what I had you cheatin son
of a bow in the Old West you gee daddy
you'd be dead
wise doing [ __ ] [ __ ] about
extra-extra and the newsboy ace playing
his [ __ ] car if that's how you saw it
why did you lie at first and try to say
it was him Bobby Lee all these years
knowing you my oh can you see this don't
put it on your [ __ ] little eyes he's
got a cheaters haircut that's what it is
I have these little Asian eyes I don't
have peripheral so every time I look how
did you know why did you put it on him
first you lied if you were telling the
truth you would have just told on a
second if you go if you want to say it's
just a gut feeling from you improv you
felt it maybe why are you trying to help
him out he just gonna throw you under
the bus yeah okay I just hit something I
got cheated all right then you're out oh
wow no I'm dick no no no come on urine
I'm with take out get out of this and
what cuz I looked at his cards win
because he was doing the thing are you
gonna defend him though no I'm
interested Pete if I was doing that and
that's how he saw him that's what he
would have said but he fight at all did
you just throw that was some lon
you want real [ __ ]
the reason why I did that was because I
got cotton in a lie right and I'm a
survivor you hadn't lied yet I know he
was doing this right cuz he's got a four
to six is that what you had
what do you mean is that what your head
you know what I had you looked at my cat
I already [ __ ] up so out of survival I
blamed it on Jay unbelievable you think
you know a guy you think you know what
God it's a checker you can bet huija to
excel really to you bill Bill's out
Bill's out [ __ ] totally but what I
had I'll go your twenty I'll raise it
for
dude I'm returning these sunglasses it's
40 to you that's 40 I'm 42 you know so
now it's 20 back to you what do you got
are you [ __ ] rested you son of a
[ __ ] how dare you look at my cards you
cost me like $11 I can't believe you did
this forgive you the thing is he the
openly showed him to everyone but you
did it and just try to use it to your
advantage
he was a pound away from me you don't
want to do it to me 10 it's 5 bucks 10
bucks yeah I did supporting you and I've
been sitting here to the Society of
provigil good boy it's not one [ __ ]
mustache whisker that says even as the
other one they're all different heights
it never turns it that's natural it's
like he took that potato peeler to his
[ __ ] I even said a [ __ ] word about
it
hoga can reveal a lot about someone like
that Bobby leads a cheater
Ellis caught in a corner couldn't escape
and so I cheated I never saw that in him
you know I just thought he was a
wonderful asian-american man be honest
with you it's like it stresses me out
the picnic at the gambling part he's a
lyin cheatin piece of [ __ ] who happens
to be asian-american so I think deep
down inside he thinks I'm a weasel bill
was flapping his cards around left and
right what he's supposed to do when
somebody showing you their cards now
look at him
I saw every single one of his hands from
the ferry first [ __ ] one I hope the
woman in his life watches this while
he's here right now she's packing up and
getting to a safe house but here's a
deal I like a cheater
I like a liar and a cheater because if
you know they're a cheater a liar then
that's just like you just factor it in
you know I mean I'm a good sportsman guy
but like he doesn't know how to hold
cards [ __ ] em I gotta go get a wheel of
cheese
that's the deal of Bern you can go
all-in for 11 bucks if I give you this
when you give me stuff you a [ __ ] about
the [ __ ] cheating I'll give you this
yeah
shut the [ __ ] up now shut you up
[Laughter]
go [ __ ] yourself
burr wins he takes this if any of us
wouldn't even wait anything with this
keep giving me these [ __ ] cards you
dealt did I know burn one and let's get
the flaw but when I put it over here I
can trust it out he's got some sort of
face card everybody all right here's the
I swear to [ __ ] god Bobby I am with
you I think what you did is so egregious
I apologize
stammering like the lion please [ __ ] you
know but I already apologized right I
understand that
don't ever robbed a bank with this guy
that would be no one [ __ ] question
did you do it Jay Jay wanted to do it
what I really Bob a bank with sandals on
finally finally the flop is [ __ ] I'm
making this game guys I'm in it for 11
bucks he's gonna go back to his room
with enough money for the handle and
then 40 another 40 40 all right and I'm
in for this now this is that extra fifty
fifteen off the 40 cuz that's all I can
fit to me forty I put in forty do you
just raised it yeah how could you put it
in sorry he went all philosophical
what's in it for me what does it all
mean man now any more betting goes to
this over here betting reminded me of
the dude from Chico and the man no one
raised you all right Bert I'm [ __ ]
Albertson I know but you still got a
deal oh sorry
burn one and then burn one over here
just get even you
Bobby's got that sinister look on his
face it's the Bobby if he wants to bet
over here I think it was ten I love that
you just did that I want you're the guy
I want to be J does that to me I want to
be like okay I think that was 10th and
just stay even-keeled two kids you're
one kid you're gonna get it yeah he'll
wait on your rug you can't be like all
right we got it buddy we'll call you
Hank you can't yell at a baby
I'm not saying a baby you say yes baby
shoot and I have I didn't yell at them
early land get on your feet or whatever
it is you gotta [ __ ] your antenna to
ease in 4/10 here comes the river BAM
[ __ ] yeah
no intense joy [ __ ] liar so YouTube
can bet against each other for that line
this is the three of you just to let you
guys know I'm holding a pair of sevens
what you need to do you guys are betting
over here who is in so far everyone's in
but you're betting on another the only
people have money left are you and Al
okay so it's your bet
okay come got twenty you sure can right
over here al that's where your that will
go as well twenty you want to raise it
all all right so everybody shows I got a
pair of jacks a pair of jacks
seven sevens a washer
Bobby has what Jackson today's what do
you have I was working I say what so
what did you have so not ace alright so
this goes like that goes here the rest
goes to the next life lesson right there
people she hit we done that's why that
pipelines gonna go underneath that
sacred ground eventually
guys like this always [ __ ] win good
job I want to say one last thing IIIi
don't feel guilty about cheating
I don't I appreciate I want to win I
want to win mmm
I would did win and I'm killing the game
right now well I mean this game later
man were you going to catch those in a
there's not real this there's no like
cashier over there you know what I even
realize how many times did he get up and
go to like look on a monitor
how many times we pay on our groom hand
and he's looking at what our hands were
and that comes back in [ __ ] he's
wearing a wire now that the game's over
I got to tell you none of us really know
how to play poker
in fact Jay Lassen the guy that knew the
most wound up with nothing a big goose
egg for Jay lassen I'm not controlling
this same result for me 0 bucks
I didn't raise the stakes at all first
guy nothing Flair's got nothing al did
okay he wound up with $153 that's
horrible terrible and guess what Eddie's
form a gambling addiction paid off with
three hundred and five bucks I'm on a
[ __ ] roll and that cheating [ __ ]
bastard Bobby Lee came out on top with
342 bucks
you son of a [ __ ] you tell me this is a
fair world and I'll show you Bobby Lee
looking at my [ __ ] cards take it
chips all right that's it thanks again
for taking a seat at the all things
comedy poker table we played poker today
with comedians and it was very
spontaneous I was the best player the
table no question that doesn't mean I'm
always gonna win they're all winners
we all got a goal I think we should
raise the stakes next time I think maybe
we should get a waitress next game I'm
just gonna play it next game I think
I'll I'll be a little less excited when
I have a good hand five sitting anywhere
near Bobby Lee I'll definitely keep him
like close to the vest there's no next
time [ __ ] this you know what I just you
know I just realized I am I'm a weasel
and I am a snake I am the snake hey you
know what
I'm 45 and I'm gonna change [ __ ] it i'ma
speak of a weasel and I'm gonna split my
way through life